[Music]
hey guys what's up this is karn from
geek culture welcome to our very first
video feature this week geek culture
attended the special launch event for
diablo 3 reaper of souls we had a chance
to sit down and talk with michael chu
senior lead designer from blizzard
entertainment so check out the interview
so it's a great honor having you here
with us today
so we know that diablo is one of the
most popular video game franchises in
the world so um
for lack of a better phrase it's one
hell of a phenomenon right so how does
it feel to be part of something so
special
well you know i i feel really lucky
because you know when i started working
in the game industry i worked on
diablo 2 lord of destruction and it's
really important game to me so when i
had the opportunity to work on diablo 3
i was i was so excited and the fact that
you know it's been well received and i
feel like the game is is really great
it's something that i'm really really
happy about and you know it's it's kind
of uh it's kind of unbelievable
wow okay that sounds awesome right
you're kind of living the dream
basically
so um a couple weeks ago so this
pre-expansion patch went live for
vanilla diablo 3. so it contained a huge
list of changes um
i haven't had the experience uh i
haven't had the opportunity to
experience it for myself so but the
people i've talked to they basically
tell me it's like a brand new game a
whole new game um
so i'd just like to know what's the
rationale behind you know this massive
overhaul of the whole game mechanics
right so after diablo 3 came out you
know we
we did a lot of post release content
patches because what we wanted to do was
sort of refine the experience we felt
that we had a good core gameplay
experience but you know we learned a lot
of stuff in release and there were a lot
of things that we could fix
then
and in the patches that came out after
that but there was a lot of stuff that
we sort of earmarked that oh when when
reaper comes out there's this there are
these things that we want to address and
one of them i think uh one of the main
ones was the the item game and so you
know what we found was item game is so
important to diablo to do the apple
franchise you know it really drives
players to to do what they do to
experience content and what we want to
do is make that more fulfilling and so
that when you are going through the game
and you're playing you know you're
getting more items that are more
meaningful you're getting a bigger
variety you know more legendaries that
kind of stuff it's all about the loot
right that's right it's all about the
loop okay
so aside from these uh
improvements to the item game that you
just mentioned um what else does reaper
of souls bring to the table and in your
opinion
how does it change up the game for the
player yeah i think the biggest thing
that uh is different in reverb souls is
the addition of adventure mode and
adventure mode very much comes out of
that same sort of thought process that
we had after releasing diablo 3. you
know we looked at the way that we were
playing the game we looked at the way
that you know the community was playing
the game and what we found is that what
people want to do is they want to play
this content they want to get more loot
they want to kill monsters but there are
things that get in the way for example
you know you want to experience the
story once you want to go through you
want to have the experience of killing
diablo but after that what you really
want to do is you want to go out there
and you want to kill and you want to
collect items and so what we decided was
well what if we gave what if we embrace
this you know this is what players want
how can we give them the best possible
experience of that so what we do is came
with this idea of adventure mode we take
we take the areas we unlock everything
we give you new gameplay objectives in
the form of bounties we also give you
nephilim rips which are extremely
randomized and different every time you
play so you know you every time you jump
in you get to choose what you want to do
you have a new experience so it's
basically all about the freedom
yeah okay so
um aside from all that you've already
mentioned um can diablo fans expect any
surprises from rebirth souls are there
going to be any like wow moments that
people are going to be talking about for
some time oh i definitely think so you
know one of the things that we were
going for uh in the campaign of uh
reaper souls in act 5 is we wanted to
embrace this idea of mystery you don't
quite know what's going on you're
introduced to this new bad guy mouth
hill uh in the cinematic and early on
you sort of see the result of what he's
been doing you see the devastation of
this great city west march and as you go
through the game what's going on becomes
clear and there are definitely some some
twists and turns i see that's good to
know but uh so i'll just take that as a
yes there are going to be some surprises
all right so
now back to vanilla diablo 3 for a bit
so
i believe it still holds the record for
the fastest selling pc game of all time
um how do you think reaper of souls is
going to measure up to that
well you know i think the way that i see
repub souls is very much like how lord
of destruction was for diablo 2. you
know we we have this great foundation of
a game and then what we want to do is we
wanted to take the things that we really
like make them stronger and then add in
features to just make the whole overall
diablo 3 experience that much better so
you know what we're really trying to do
is you know focus on that foundation and
then just kind of improve and make it
make it the sort of platform you know
the sort of game that you can continue
to play and just experience okay so
diablo 3. huge launch
3 million copies sold on day one
uh
that's awesome in itself but uh it also
brought about you know some problems so
people couldn't really log into the game
error 37 blah blah you know the rest so
i'd just like to know you know how has
the team at blizzard um
anticipated today's launch how how have
they prepared to you know uh deal with
this influx of friends so obviously
after the launch of the three we learned
a lot of lessons you know about there's
some things that you just it's hard to
know until you know it actually happens
right now you know that we're armed this
information and it's years later we've
we i think we've learned our lessons and
we're much better prepared to uh to
handle this launch uh well i guess
coming from you this sounds reassuring
i'm glad i'm sure the fans will be glad
to hear that so
um just let's talk a little about the
development of the game so
during the course of development you
must have talked to your team lots of
times about you know what to add what
change and so on
is there one feature that was ultimately
thrown out but you wish had stayed in
the game
um
i think one of the things we talked a
little bit about is this
uh i think uh devil's hand and it's a
sort of uh item collection mechanic and
i think it was very interesting but it
came about very late in uh in
development and i think uh the sort of
approach that we take at blizzard is you
know you want to provide every feature
that you put in you want it to be fully
realized you want to be iterated upon
you know you want it to be something
that stands alone and just adding in
extra features for future sake doesn't
really do much so we ended up focusing
on new features like adventure mode and
really um cleaning up streamlining and
making the campaign the best experience
possible okay uh but the way you mention
it sounds very exciting do you think
it's possible that it might make it into
the game eventually somehow um i i don't
know but it was just an interesting idea
but you know we have lots of interesting
ideas i'm sure so um
on the flip side of all the things that
actually did make it into the game um
which is the one feature that you're
most proud of well i think it would have
to be adventure mode because i think
that it really enables um you know the
way what it's really giving players what
they want you know it's a way that they
can continue to play diablo and continue
to kill monsters still have these new
experiences and i think it's just it's
really the thing that separates reaper
right so listening to the fans basically
um
i think we all know that the diablo
community can be quite a vocal bunch i
mean all gamers are nowadays everyone's
a critic so
um tell me as a writer and a designer um
how do you maintain that balance between
giving the fans what they want versus
your own uh artistic vision of how the
game should be right so i think what's
important is that you know it's it's
always important to accept feedback and
that's something that blizzard always
does we're very
um we go on the forums we listen to
social media and what we do is we look
for trends we look for patterns and
honestly a lot of things that um our
players ask for are things that we want
ourselves and you know when we identify
things like that what we do is we make
sure that we don't overreact you know we
want to figure out what is the cause of
the issue and then figure out a smart
solution to it okay so
you're sort of going by the uh
by players four players kind of wrong
because you guys enjoy the game yourself
that's i mean that's the thing at
blizzard we love playing our own games
and we're our own harshest critics and
when we go about you know making futures
making games one of the first things we
look for is is this something that i
would love because if i love it probably
other people will too right that's
really good to know coming from you the
lead designer so now that you've shipped
reaper of souls uh could you tell us a
little more about what's next for you
and your team uh could we expect more
expansions uh
a sequel maybe or maybe even a brand new
game well i can't talk about too much
but you know what i can say is that
after blizzard completes a project you
know we are very focused on
uh maintaining that project and making
sure that you know we release patches
and sort of
uh make sure that you know it's
something that we feel really satisfied
with
all right so
um well we hope to hear more from you in
the days to come with regards to new
game releases
updates expansions um would definitely
keep our eyes peeled um so i'm afraid
we're almost out of time um do you have
any parting words for all the diablo
fans out there yeah i mean i think
definitely check out reaper souls i feel
like
it is sort of the spiritual successor
for what lord of destruction was to
diablo 2. it enabled it really opens up
the game you get a new new campaign get
to see all sorts of new environments new
hero and then you can play adventure
mode and have as much fun as you want
all right awesome so uh thank you so
much for your time michael thank you uh
no doubt that reproducible is going to
be a great game i wish you all the best
and we hope to see you here again in
singapore sometime soon
all right i hope you guys enjoyed the
interview let us know your thoughts in
the comments below
for more of all things geeky please
visit geekculture.co and don't forget to
like us on facebook the buttons should
be floating around somewhere here
stay tuned to us for our review of
diablo 3 reaper of souls see you guys
later